des élus locaux des universitaires et
des élèves du lycée international de
saint germain en laye tous sont venus
célébrer les 20 ans de la maison de
l'europe des yvelines une structure
d'information sur les politiques
européennes
un outil essentiel sur les territoires
pour les institutions européennes avec
la maison de l'europe mais surtout avec
les cendrillons délecte ce qu'on veut
c'est s'est rapproché de citoyennes et
citoyens voire entre rapport au peu près
de sa maison auquel il peut faire
entendre sa voir écouter ce qu'ils ont
besoin d'information et participer dans
la vie européenne comme citoyens
européens que sont il est important de
faire connaître l'europe c'est notre
mission de faire connaître l'europe ces
institutions ce que l'europe fait pour
les français au quotidien c'est quelque
chose que nous ignorons beaucoup encore
trop je trouve cet anniversaire
l'occasion de rappeler cette mission
d'information objectif démontrer
l'utilité de l'union européenne pour
certains gènes cette organisation a un
intérêt au niveau international la voix
de tous les pays commente dans cette
organisation est aussi ça permet de
donner une visibilité à tous les pays et
sur le plan international
ça permet de pas avoir de guerre pour
moi et
aussi deux pour les pays de l'union
pérenne de s'entraider concernant la
présence européenne dans la vie
quotidienne des français un travail
pédagogique est encore nécessaire enfin
dans ma vie quotidienne je trouve pas
trop que l'europe est une grande
importance après j'imagine que dans les
cadres des programmes comme erasmus ou
des choses comme ça ça peut
effectivement aider comme je suis
italienne et française je peux voyager
souvent en italie et je pense que ça
aide pas mal le fait qu'il ya une union
où voyagent pas mal dans l'europe et oui
six ans en 2022 38 maison de l'europe
sont en activité sur l'ensemble du
territoire français